last Ron DeSantis discussion for today
and then we're going to move on to some
other things
a completely and totally deranged Ron
DeSantis appeared on Fox and Friends and
said that if he is elected president he
will destroy leftism destroy leftism
I think he might actually believe this
which is the scariest part that's right
now the time for Ron DeSantis to run for
president
because the everyone knows if I'm the
nominee I will beat Biden and I will
serve two terms and I will be able to
destroy leftism in this country and
leave woke ideology on the Dustbin of
History okay so that's a lot if I'm
President we will end Chicken and
Waffles it's just either you want Savory
or you want sweet but we're not going to
allow these leftists from New York City
to come in and tell us that you're going
to put maple syrup on Fried Chicken it's
just not gonna happen and it will be
left for the dust spin of History this
is extraordinarily dangerous what he is
saying and there are about a dozen
different concerns with it and
um I'm going to tell you about some of
them now first of all yesterday I played
a clip for you of Ron DeSantis saying
he'd consider pardoning Donald Trump and
meanwhile he's saying that he's going to
destroy leftism from a purely tactical
standpoint I don't see how you win a
Republican primary you're losing to
Trump by 30. by saying you'll pardon
Trump and only talking about Joe Biden
now I know that we've talked about this
before we talked about it at the top of
the show and I know there is
disagreement in my audience about the
strategy of DeSantis running against
Biden the idea is by the most positive
spin we can put on DeSantis only talking
about mostly talking about Joe Biden
right now is that people who see him
will see him as the nominee and will
Envision and imagine what it would be
like for him to run against Joe Biden
rather than seeing him getting chippy
with Donald Trump
they see him as the Challenger to Biden
and they might say oh I can see this
working better than what it was like in
2020 when Trump ran against Joe Biden so
the idea is to plant the vision in the
minds of Voters of hey this guy could be
the nominee this is what it would be
like however however I don't see how
just saying stuff like I will destroy
leftism and Biden is bad is going to get
Trump supporters to say maybe I will go
for DeSantis and I also don't know how
it's going to bring in new voters into
the Republican primary so as a strategy
I don't really get it second it's really
important to remember with all of this
anti-woke stuff most people are on the
woke side not the anti-woke side the
leftism that DeSantis says he will
destroy
is increasingly what Americans believe
we have numerous polls at this point
these are not outlier polls in any way
which not by a huge margin but like 55
to 45 57 to 43 60 to 40. when you ask
Americans their views on what we might
consider issues of wokeness right views
on inclusivity views on trans people
views on drag shows and book Banning and
race relations and these sorts of things
people the country is coming out
on the side of wokeness and so DeSantis
maybe this would work in Florida I mean
it in a sense it did because he won by
19 I believe it was in his re-election
campaign to Governor the math isn't
there
for it working nationally he says he's
going to destroy the movement that is
the foremost movement defending human
rights right now the Republican party is
not the party of Defending human rights
economic Justice LGBT rights uh
defending the climate teaching kids
critical thinking I could go on and on
that's the movement DeSantis says he
wants to destroy so forget about I don't
know that this will win in the primary I
don't think that this will win him a
general election either and then we get
to the third aspect of this and this is
really the saddest one and one that is
more in line with a lot of the things
we've talked about on this program this
is a totally anti-intellectual argument
and I know that the the Republican party
has become the anti and
pseudo-intellectual party it's been this
way for decades instead of engaging with
specific ideas and trying to refute the
evidence put forth by the left the left
of which I consider myself apart
DeSantis is either interested or you
might even say obsessed with just
dismissing the entire left outright and
the dismissive attitude is also towards
intellectual discourse it's towards
higher education it's work towards
learning and thinking and epistemology
and media literacy and critical thinking
and all of those things and we can say
oh it's because he's pandering to dumb
Republicans okay yeah there are
Republicans that are dumb but the danger
in it is that it undermines the
Democratic process because it gets
people thinking about elections or
better said not really thinking about
them in ways that allow the Democratic
process to be corroded which we saw on
January 6th and which we've seen other
attempts made trying to overturn the
election Etc and then lastly
he's going to need I mean listen I don't
know that I would say DeSantis needs
Progressive support to win but he
certainly needs moderate support
probably Sun some Center left people who
might say I don't really like Biden and
while DeSantis is to my right I'm going
to vote for him because he's extending
an olive branch and reaching out to me
when you say I will destroy leftism you
blatantly ignore and debase your
Progressive constituents and DeSantis in
that way is going to shut himself off
from even maybe getting a little bit of
that voter base he's limiting his voter
base to the most extreme elements of the
Republican party and I guess like
right-leaning Independence maybe but the
open-minded Independence to the extent
that they exist left-leaning
Independence Centrist Democrats some of
whom DeSantis might be able to pick up
if he had a more conciliatory tone he's
going to lose all of them without with I
will destroy leftism so right now
desantis's approach doesn't seem like a
viable approach to defeating Donald
Trump to even secure this nomination and
it certainly doesn't seem like a viable
approach to defeating Joe Biden in the
next couple days and maybe even by
tomorrow in time for tomorrow's show we
will have post announcement polling in a
hypothetical matchup against Biden I'm
curious to see what that will look like
make sure you're following us on Tick
Tock where we are approaching
this is an unbelievable number we are
approaching half a million Tick Tock
followers we have not grown this quickly
on any platform ever
make sure you're following us on Tick
Tock and make sure you're subscribed on
the YouTube channel as well